- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for joining
us at this town meeting.
I'm Kim Goff-Crews,
Secretary and Vice President
for University Life.
Before I turn things over
to President Salovey,
I wanna take a moment to talk to you
a little bit about the meeting format.
We solicited questions in the (mumbles)
and we received hundreds.
So we've grouped the questions
into a series of themes,
and the presentation will address
many of those themes.
We do know, however, that
the presentation itself
may suggest that you have other questions,
and we ask that if you do,
that you fill out the form on the web page
that allowed you to
get into this broadcast
so that we can track them.
If we have time,
we'll answer some of the questions live,
but we will keep all the
questions and make sure
that they go to the
correct university leader.
Now after today, the covid19.yale.edu
and Yale Today will continue to be
good sources of information,
so please check them often.
And one final note,
this meeting is being recorded
because we wanna make sure that if people
are not available to see it,
that they have an opportunity to do so.
And with that, I'm
going to turn everything
over to President Salovey.
Thank you.
- Well, thank you, Kim, and
good afternoon, everyone.
I'm very grateful to be able to connect
with all of you during
this unsettling time
in New Haven, across the United States,
really around the globe.
We've been seeing a global disruption
at a scale that hasn't been
experienced in generations.
In recent months, we've
had to alter our lives
dramatically to contain
the spread of COVID-19.
I know that many of you
have been confronting
the reality that intermediate
and long-term plans have been upended.
You've made sacrifices,
you've experienced disappointments.
Some of you have family members
and friends who are out of work
and who are worried about
supporting their families.
And of course, some of you are caring
for someone who is sick,
or you may be sick yourselves.
I've lost someone in my extended family,
and to those of you who
have also lost loved ones,
I'm deeply, deeply sorry.
Today though, I believe
it is also important
to express my gratitude
for the way our community
has come together to overcome challenges,
to take care of one another,
to take care of our world.
To the Yale community,
I'm thankful for your optimism,
for your resilience,
for your selflessness.
Thank you for working hard to maintain
the core functions of our university,
especially during these challenging times.
Our staff, whether on
campus or working remotely,
have really kept this place going.
A faculty through their
willingness to teach
in new ways has ensured that we continue
to educate students and create knowledge.
And our students have worked hard
to continue their learning online.
To those of you who
are healthcare workers,
you're our heroes.
And I'm grateful to colleagues across Yale
who are coordinating with
the City of New Haven
and with the state of Connecticut as well.
Working collaboratively with people
across our city and across our state,
we can support one another.
We can share research findings,
we can share best practices,
we can share strategic planning.
I believe we'll get through this,
and we'll get through this especially
if we remain a unified Yale.
In this period of uncertainty,
I know that everyone wants as much clarity
as possible about what Yale will do
in the weeks and in the months ahead.
For the next hour, my colleagues and I
will address your most pressing questions,
and they fall into three themes:
the health and safety of our community,
preparing for financial challenges,
and preparing for getting
the campus up and running.
We'll then answer some of the questions
you submitted during the meeting.
I have to say though,
much of what we're gonna
talk about reflects
planning that is still in progress,
so you have to think of
this as a progress report.
Okay, one of the most
commonly asked questions
is some version of how is the
university making decisions?
We wanna share with you
some of the key principles
that we use to plan and to take action.
First, we will act to protect the health
and safety of Yale faculty, staff,
students, and neighbors.
This is a first principle,
all of our actions so far reflect the fact
that we view this as a
public health crisis first.
Decisions about health and safety
made by the university in the context
of COVID-19 will be evidence-based,
data-driven to the extent possible.
To me, this is what universities must do.
We need to model what it
means to rely on experts,
on data, and on analysis
to decide among options.
This really isn't the
moment for gut feelings.
Our decisions should sustain and advance,
whenever possible, the quality of teaching
and research at Yale.
We need to preserve our core mission,
our missions that have engaged
this university for 319 years.
We must take the long view in how we think
about our human and our
financial resources.
And I wanna be clear,
we will be educating our
students in the fall.
We don't know yet in what manner,
but we'll be teaching and
creating new knowledge.
The diversity and excellence
of our student body
is of fundamental importance,
and we won't compromise the ability
to educate students,
regardless of family background.
This means we need to
protect the financial
support that we provide to students,
especially those from the
least affluent families.
Finally, the university-wide priorities
that I've been talking about for the past
few years have not changed,
and decision-making will continue
to reflect those priorities.
Now what I'd like to do is move
to another frequently asked question.
Many of you inquired about the status
of COVID-19 in New Haven,
and what Yale is doing to combat it.
So Nancy Brown is the
Jean and David Wallace
dean of the Yale School of Medicine,
and she's here with us.
So, Nancy, how is Yale Medicine,
the Yale medical school and our partners
at Yale New Haven Hospital prepared
to face down this virus?
Can you tell us a little
bit about their preparations
and the current situation,
the outlook for the virus in New Haven
and in the state of Connecticut,
and what's it gonna take,
what's it gonna take from a medical
and public health point of view
to resume activities on our campus?
Nancy.
- Thank you, Peter.
Let me start by framing where we are
and from whence we've come.
It's hard to believe but
the first case of COVID
was diagnosed in Connecticut on March 7th.
And on the left, you can see the trend
in positive cases on the top,
and in the number of deaths per day
on the bottom in Connecticut.
On the right, you see the number
of COVID-19 patients hospitalized
in our own Yale New Haven hospitals,
and as you can see, we are
seeing a downturn as well,
but that at our peak,
we had as many as 450 patients
in Yale New Haven Hospital
with approximately
70 of those patients on ventilators.
Next slide.
There's been much work at Yale Health,
Yale Medicine, and Yale
New Haven Health System
leading up to the first case of COVID
and continuing to make
sure that we could care
for our patients safely.
This included an early focus on testing,
and Marie Landry, shown here,
developed the first approved
viral tests in Connecticut,
and the first test at an academic
medical center anywhere.
Yale Health prepared space for patients,
and physicians such as Jonathan Siner
stood up three floors of
the Smilow Cancer center
as new intensive care space
for our COVID-positive patients.
And we reduced the number
of elective surgeries
and outpatient visits to make room
for these patients.
We also innovated to make
sure that we have adequate
personal protective
equipment and ventilators.
Next.
Early on, we realized that
we needed to coordinate
our research and our clinical responses
to fight COVID across
the School of Medicine,
the hospital, and the university,
and so we created the
COVID-19 Coordination
Response Team, or CoRreCT.
And here I must give
credit to Ruth Montgomery
for the naming.
And today this includes
members of the FAS,
the schools of engineering, medicine,
nursing, public health,
as well as the Yale New
Haven Health System.
We created a web presence that could serve
as a repository for research protocols
and preprints so that our investigators
and clinicians could see data
as soon as it became available.
And investigators at
Yale have been involved
in discovery science,
understanding the mechanism of infection,
and importantly, the host response,
as well as in vaccine development,
therapeutic trials, and
seminal epidemiologic studies.
This webpage also provides continually
updated clinical protocols,
and these clinical
protocols have been informed
by conversations with colleagues in China,
Italy, Washington, and New York,
and by our own evolving experience
as we learn about COVID-19.
Next slide.
We know that the effects of COVID-19
are more severe in older patients
as well as those who have obesity
or diabetes and hypertension,
but we have also learned that the severity
of COVID-19 is greater in patients
of African or Hispanic descent.
We've leveraged a wonderful group
called the Cultural Ambassadors.
These are ministers from
the Connecticut AME Church
and members of Junta
for Progressive Action
who have been advocates for many years
for clinical research to get the word out
about the ways in which we
might limit COVID infections
and how patients can (murmurs).
We also understand that social distancing
and all the measures we
have taken to flatten
the curve have significant
effects on the economy,
and therefore the long-term
health of our community.
And Yale economists and social scientists
have been advising local, state,
and national government on ways
to reduce the impact.
A group of faculty from the
schools of public health,
nursing, medicine, and management,
as well as Yale Health
have been meeting daily
to address the conditions
necessary for reopening.
One member of this group, Albert Ko,
is a member of the governor's
task force on reopening.
Much has been written about the conditions
that are requisite, and
this chart on the left
is one that I find very simple but useful
from Resolve to Save Lives.
And I think what you
can see from the graphs
that I showed at the beginning
that we are starting to
meet many of the conditions
such as the decline in the number of cases
and deaths in Connecticut.
But we've also done a lot to ensure
that we have adequate
personal protective equipment.
Many think tanks have issued reports
and we will use these as
well as our own expertise
on campus to guide our plans for reopening
in the context of both
national and state guidance.
Peter, thank you.
- I wrote to the Yale community
about the two big issues facing us
beyond the immediate health crisis,
how is COVID-19 affecting
Yale financially,
and what are we planning
to do in the fall?
Provost Scott Strobel
is leading the effort
on both of these fronts,
and so why don't we turn to him.
Scott, why don't we start with finances?
- Thanks, Peter.
It's a pleasure to talk to you today
about those questions.
Like many of you,
my household has been impacted by this.
A few months ago, it was my wife and I
alone in our home.
We now have eight people living here
as my two adult children and their spouses
and their two children now live with us,
including a three-year-old granddaughter.
Turns out Nora's looking for distraction,
and one of the things she likes to do
is we every now and then go for a drive
to just get out of the
house for a few minutes.
As we come to the driveway,
she begs from her car
seat that she might have
the opportunity to
steer into the driveway.
So before you call DCF,
this is just a few hundred,
a few dozen feet before
we reach the driveway,
and she needs to make a right-hand turn.
What we've realized as she's done this
is she fails to recognize
that as we approach that turn,
she needs to begin turning the wheel.
Instead, she assumes that she can begin
to turn as the corner is reached
rather than turning it in advance.
In some sense, this is a allegory
of what it is that we're headed for
and what we're trying
to manage as we consider
the financial implications
that are now faced
by the university.
We do not yet know the full magnitude
of the turn that we need to make,
but we do know that we need
to start making that turn.
Anybody who's looked at the headlines
in the past few weeks
recognizes that this pandemic
is causing huge economic impact.
Entire economies around
the world are in lockdown.
Unemployment rates have now hit 30 million
in the United States alone,
which is an unemployment
rate approaching 20%,
which is the highest level since 1934
at the heart of the depression.
Financial markets have fallen steeply,
and while they have recovered partially,
they are still highly
volatile and clearly unknown
for future days and weeks and months.
The gross domestic products,
which is the broadest measure of goods
and services in the country,
fell by almost 5% in the first quarter,
which was not a full COVID quarter,
and it's likely to follow
still substantially
more in the coming quarter.
But what does all this mean for Yale?
What is the magnitude of the curve
that we need to make?
What is this turn we need to begin to make
and begin to follow?
Those are the questions that, of course,
we need to consider.
And as I answer that question,
I would like to consider
them in sort of three phases,
the first phase being
effectively this year,
this financial year,
which is fiscal year 20,
which began last July and continues
through June of this year.
Then there is the medium term,
which is effectively
what happens next year.
And then the longer term,
which is what happens over the next
one to five years.
As you know, Yale has four
main sources of funding.
These include tuition, fundraising,
the generosity of our donors,
returns on the endowment,
and clinical medical services.
Those are the main ways
that we receive revenue,
and use that revenue to
pay the various expenses
that run the university.
Over the past few months,
just the months of March and April,
the unexpected, unanticipated
impact of COVID-19
on our budget is
approximately $200 million.
This is in the form of both reduced income
and new COVID-specific costs.
This includes the refund that we made
to the room and board for
students in our housing.
It includes the reduced clinical revenue
as a result of performing fewer elective
procedures in our hospital.
It includes fewer gifts
from our generous donors.
It includes the reduction
in sponsored awards
from the research that's
underway in our laboratories.
We've put up a field hospital.
That had a cost.
We lost revenue as a result of the summer
programs that we normally
have for students
that visit Yale during the summer months.
As a result, we see a
substantial reduction
in our revenue that of course
hits directly to our bottom line.
The good news is the
university has sufficient
reserves that we can
manage this one-time shock.
We budget conservatively,
and we act prudently,
and so if this was a one-time impact,
we would be able to easily,
not easily, but we would be able to manage
the beginning of this turn.
But we anticipate that
this is just the beginning
of the turn.
There are other high
levels of uncertainty.
Let me give you just a few examples.
As we begin consideration of the FY 21,
the fiscal year 21 budget,
which is next year's financial budget,
we can already see that
there will be greater need
for financial aid for our students.
There is a significant level
of tuition uncertainty,
particularly for students
that are from international
locations that may not
be able to get to campus.
Not because of a lack of interest
or a lack of desire on our part,
but challenges with their visa status
and being able to get
the visas that they need,
the paperwork they need
to be able to come to the country.
It will have impact on the endowment
that is still yet to be understood
in relation to the markets.
And it's also possible
that this will continue
to impact the gifts that
we receive from our donors.
Because the magnitude
of the turn is unknown
and will not be known for several months
or even a couple of years,
we have begun to make the turn
without fully knowing its magnitude.
And to begin that turn,
we have announced several
actions for the coming year,
and these were
announcements that were made
just over a week and a half ago.
It included a 5% reduction in spending.
This is a reduction in the general account
spending that is used to fund programs
across the university.
And this 5% reduction
will largely be achieved
through other things that we announced
at that same time,
namely a pause in hiring through next year
with few exceptions that are permitted
or allowed with appeal of the provost
or the dean of medicine,
a salary freeze for the coming year,
reduced spending on building projects
in which we removed
$300 million of capital
spending from projects
over the next two years,
as well as a reduction in travel and other
discretionary spending
for the coming year.
So that identifies the actions
that we are going to
take for the coming year,
but then the question is what happens
in that period and beyond?
What happens over that
period of one to five years?
And that is the area in which there is
still high uncertainty.
How steep is the economic downturn?
How fast or slow will the recovery be,
and will that recovery be a U-shape,
or a V-shape, or a W-shape?
The answers to those kinds of questions
will obviously directly impact our ability
to handle this financial storm.
How long does the pandemic last,
and how quickly is a treatment
or a vaccine identified?
Because first and foremost,
this is a public safety issue,
a public health issue with consideration
as a priority given to our faculty,
staff, and students.
And so we are trying to manage this first
and foremost with the community's health
and wellbeing in mind.
How large is the impact on the endowment,
which fundamentally is at the core
of what we can afford,
given the large fraction
of our budget that it provides.
And how does that impact get incorporated
into the budget over time?
That is a question that we are still
seeking to understand.
The question that is
most often asked of me
and probably most often
asked by many of us is,
why is it that we can't just spend
more of the endowment
to cover the financial
short we have experienced
or may experience
in the coming years?
Why can't we change the spending rule
so that we can cover
anything that might be needed
utilizing the large size
of the endowment to do so?
I think that's an interesting question,
and it's an important question.
It's a question that requires an answer
that appreciates the long-term priority
that the endowment provides,
the long-time support that the endowment
provides to the university.
And so I turn it back to you, Peter,
somebody who was a provost for many years
and has been president
for still several more
to help us understand the importance
of the endowment in managing
our budgets and finances.
- Great, thank you, Scott, and thank you
for that discussion of our budget.
So the question is,
why can't we spend more
from the endowment?
It is true, I'm asked that question a lot.
It's very important to recognize
that the endowment is
not a budget surplus.
It's not a rainy day fund.
What the endowment is,
is a collection of gifts,
a collection of gifts
given to the university
by generous donors, mostly alumni,
over the course of the
university's history.
And these gifts are
restricted by the donors
in how they can be used.
For example, there are
gifts for financial aid,
there are gifts for professorships,
there are gifts for student activities.
These gifts are invested
and they grow over time.
Based on a policy that ensures that future
generations have the same financial
resources that we do now,
not more, not less,
the same financial
resources that we do now,
we spend a certain amount
from the endowment every year.
It's about 5 1/4% percent of the value
of the endowment.
That's actually a lot of money.
This year, that's about $1.4 billion.
It's more than a third
of our operating budget
of the entire university.
And if we were to leave
out the medical school,
it's more than half of
the operating budget
for the rest of the university.
So to do this year after year,
the endowment must grow,
enough to make up what we spend for it.
I'm sorry, enough to make
up what we spend from it,
plus inflation.
So the endowment has to grow,
on average, the amount
we spend plus inflation.
So I asked the investments office
to give me an estimate of what will happen
to the endowment this year, next year,
and the following years,
and they are expecting the following.
They are expecting a
recession for some time,
and eventually a recovery.
And when we look at the
amount of the endowment
we can spend based on their predictions,
we can compare it to the amount we thought
we could spend before
the COVID-19 pandemic,
and there's a difference.
A few years from now,
we could have 300 to $400 million per year
less to spend than we had
originally anticipated.
And that's why we're taking the actions
that we're taking now,
to blunt the impact of this
anticipated drop in funds,
as Scott described.
This is the turn that we are anticipating
well in advance of making it,
and so it's the budgetary framework
within which we're working.
We'll keep the community
updated as the financial
picture becomes clearer and clearer.
Let's turn though now to questions
about the future including
the fall semester.
Scott, I'd like to ask you frame
that issue as well.
- Thanks.
So as the community knows,
I started as provost
on January 1st in 2020.
This was not particularly
good timing on my part.
I had been in the job just over two months
when the pandemic hit.
I think I at that point had figured
out where my office was and had managed
to bring in some of my books.
But here we are.
So in the course of the first
hundred days in the job,
and I should say that I've at least
been in the job longer than Nancy has.
She started on February 1st,
so we have done a lot
of on-the-job training.
During the first hundred
days in this role,
we have moved classes online.
That was an announcement on March 10th.
Of course, these are all announcements
that you and the community have received.
We asked the community to work
from home on March 16th.
We stopped non-essential research
in laboratories and libraries,
we've postponed commencement of reunions,
we canceled summer events and travel,
and extended the work from home policy
through the end of May
just over a week ago.
The second half of spring semester 2020
will be memorable to all of us.
It was the semester that we converted
from a residential university
to doing online education.
It was not perfect, but
I think it worked better
than many of us expected.
We demonstrated how
resilient this community is,
and overall, I think it
was an impressive effort.
I would specifically
want to thank the faculty
and graduate students for their hard work
in delivering their courses in a format
that none of us imagined
or even contemplated
as the semester began.
I mentioned I'm sure that I'm probably
not the only one who is managing demands
of a child in a house as you consider
how you have juggled the various pressures
on your time over these
past several weeks.
I want to thank you, I
want to thank the faculty,
the staff, and the
students for their patience
in a learning environment
that is very different
than what they imagined when we started.
Work has changed, teaching has changed.
Critical research has continued.
That includes research
that's going on still
in our laboratories focused on COVID-19,
some of which Nancy described to you,
research to expand testing,
to engineer increased ventilator capacity,
to do clinical studies on drug treatments
that will lessen the
symptoms of this disease,
and of course, the frontline doctors,
nurses, and patient-facing staff
who are heroes in this pandemic.
The question all of us want to know
is what happens next?
The way I phrase it is,
what will I do on my
second 100 days in the job?
When will laboratories be reactivated
for non-COVID research?
When will the library be open again
so that we can do work in the social
sciences and humanities?
When will we be able to go back to work?
Will the university be
open in the fall semester?
Will we be online or
will we welcome students
back to the campus?
These continue to be difficult questions,
and we do not yet have final answers.
But we are taking each
of them systematically,
carefully, expeditiously with input
from across the campus to understand
what the answers to those
questions should be.
Last week, President
Salovey announced a process
for addressing these important questions
that employs six faculty committees
seeking input from over
65 different faculty
and additional senior administrators
who have experience from
across the university.
They will in turn or are
in turn still seeking
further consultation from faculty,
students, and staff to
identify what the answers
to these questions should be.
Let me briefly introduce
you to those committees,
the work that they're doing,
and the way they're
approaching their mandate.
First and foremost, we want to follow
the public health advice,
and so the first committee
is the Public Health Advisory Committee
that provides guidance for the protocols
and procedures and
directions we will follow
as we consider any other action
that the university will take.
The second is the
Research Continuity Group
recognizing that it will be possible
to reactivate our
laboratories and our libraries
before it will be possible
to reactivate the work
that goes on in our
classrooms and dining halls.
This group is defining how to do safe labs
and libraries with clear
protocols and standards.
There is also an Academic Continuity group
that is chaired by Pericles Lewis.
Pericles will be talking
to us about the details
of his work in a minute.
But I want to identify what that group
was charged to do.
One of the challenges
that I have in thinking
about the decision-making process in this
is that it all becomes a
question of probabilities
of certain things falling into line.
Will there be sufficient testing?
Will there be sufficient PPE?
And so to pull apart
that probability question
and make it possible to just think clearly
about the possibilities in front of us,
we have asked one of the subcommittees
under Academic Continuity
to think about the question,
what is the best version
of an online education
that we can provide,
recognizing that we
now have several months
to prepare for it if that's what we end up
needing to do in the fall?
So that's the thinking of one group.
There's also a second
group that is thinking
about the question,
what is the best version
of a safe residential in-person education
that we can provide in the fall,
recognizing that we will
be under constraints
for public health considerations?
Those two considerations, those two groups
thinking in parallel with each other
we think will (murmurs)
the best possible version
of what eventually becomes our decision
for the fall semester.
There's also a group considering
what are we doing in
the creative practice,
specifically around the arts?
For example, this
represents particularly new
and different questions,
different than what's being considered
in the other two groups:
How do you socially distance a play,
or how do you socially
distance an orchestra?
So what it means to bring the arts groups,
reactivate the arts groups
is an important question.
All of this will be informed by a group
that's thinking about operations.
How do we reimagine work?
How do we reimagine teaching and research?
And this group has considerations
from human resources facilities,
IT, and hospitality.
Of course, we need to make an answer soon,
and the sooner we can make an answer,
the better it will be for our community
as you plan for what will
happen in coming days,
weeks, and months.
We are committed to giving an answer
for what will happen in the fall semester
no later than early July.
So this will be approximately
two months from now,
giving us approximately two months
to then make final plans
for what the fall semester
will look like.
With those committees at work,
I should say that they are
working incredibly hard.
They have made major time commitments
to get this work done,
and I am very impressed
with the deliberations
that they are already making,
but of course, we all
want to know the answer
to the questions that they
have been tasked to answer.
Peter.
- So I think we should turn to Pericles
and ask him to tell us a little bit
particularly about the
work of his committee
and what it is planning with
respect to the educational
mission of the university.
- Thank you, Peter and Scott.
Yale, of course, has been
educating young people
for service for 319 years.
The educational mission of
the university is paramount,
second only to the health
and safety of our staff,
our faculty, and our students,
and we need to be prepared to continue
this mission in the fall semester.
Like many peer colleges and universities,
we're looking at two main scenarios
for planning purposes,
and we'll probably wind up
with a hybrid of the two.
If we are unable to come
together in person in the fall,
we will provide remote or online options.
That's, in a sense, scenario one.
We realize that this is not ideal.
I've been a professor
at Yale for 22 years,
and I know that nobody comes here
in order to take online courses,
or you wanna be here in
order to meet the faculty
and interact with your peers.
But we know that some students,
including some international students,
or those with health issues,
or those otherwise unable to travel
may not be able to make it to New Haven
in time for the start of classes,
and there's the risk of a second wave
of infection that might
delay in-person opening.
So we're preparing for
the online possibility.
Our faculty and staff worked very hard
over spring break to
get the spring semester
courses up and running online
in an emergency situation.
There were challenges,
but as Scott mentioned,
I think the outcome was better
than many of us had expected.
We now have the summer
ahead of us to make sure
that we provide this form of education
even more efficiently and effectively,
and this means improvements in technology
and course design.
So I'm grateful to staff and faculty
who are working together to prepare
more effective online and remote versions
of courses for the fall,
should they be necessary.
The second option, of
course, is to meet in person,
and if the public health
conditions warrant it,
we'll be providing that
in-person education,
including residential
and extracurricular life.
At spring break we had to close down
the residential colleges
and some other facilities
very, very quickly.
The reopening is likely
to be more gradual,
and we'll need time to be prepared
for evolving circumstances,
and also for any public health conditions
such as social distancing and so on
that may be necessary,
even if we are back
here in person together.
There's a lot of uncertainty,
but our goal has been
to make the campus ready
for students to return
sometime in the fall,
as early as possible in the fall.
Initially this may be in smaller groups
and we may have some hybrid of in-person
and online teaching.
It won't be exactly the
same in the graduate
and professional schools
as it is in the college.
We're looking at safe
ways of housing students,
including providing
facilities for quarantine
and for self-isolation,
enabling contact tracing
in case there's a second
wave of infection,
and of course, being prepared to treat
anyone who falls ill.
We plan to keep the campus informed
as this discussion proceeds,
and we'll provide more
detail in early summer.
I realize that it's frustrating
not to be able to give a detailed account
of each of these scenarios at the moment,
but we've been sort of trying to plan
out all the various
options and recognizing
the complexity of the problem,
and we want to present the president
and the provost with an adequate map
for making this decision.
Now Peter and Scott and I,
and all of our faculty and staff
are committed to Yale's
educational mission.
It's never been more
important than it is now.
Yale has been through many
crises in its history,
and this is, as far as I'm concerned,
it's the biggest crisis I've ever seen,
and I imagine it's the biggest crisis
that many of us have ever encountered.
But we're a strong community and I think
we will come through this and ensure
that all Yale students
get an excellent education
in the years to come.
So thank you, Peter and Scott.
- Great, thank you very much, Pericles.
Kim, I wanna throw this back to you.
In your role as vice
president for university life,
what concerns have your
team been working on
and preparing for,
especially in this context
of so much uncertainty?
Kim.
- So what I was saying
was that one of the things
our staff hears a lot about are people
feeling a loss of people and place,
because we're all scattered
all over New Haven,
all over the state, many of us,
all over the country and the world.
And we miss, people talk
about missing interacting
with their colleagues
and their classmates,
pursuing their work and activities,
and actually physically being on campus
and in New Haven.
And Zoom sometimes just
doesn't do it for everybody.
I know for me, I miss
seeing Trey, and Jennifer,
and Felix, and the custodial staff
and SSS when I come in.
Or, like many of you, I'm
tired of my own cooking.
I wouldn't mind going to a
dining hall at the moment,
going to Berkeley College,
which I go to a lot and seeing Lynette
and having a good meal.
Or even walking around the grounds
of the facility so (mumbles) prepares
around this time of year.
So I know most of you are missing
being here physically.
But we have to sustain
a sense of community,
and we have a lot of staff who are working
very hard to do that.
We recognize and hear about challenges,
and certainly we've all
talked about the fact
that people have concerns about childcare,
about the internet
connections that they have
for themselves and their children,
and of course, the need
to support faculty,
sorry, family members who are sick
or who may have lost jobs.
So we continue to support them as well.
And we're paying particular attention to,
in particular, mental
health and wellbeing.
We have a lot of colleagues
around the university
who are working very hard to support
the community on that.
The Being Well at Yale program
which supports staff and faculty
has been putting a lot
of its programs online,
and they report that there
are increased numbers
of people dropping in to
the meditation sessions,
and also to stretching exercise classes,
which is good to hear.
We continue to support
students who might have needs
for mental health and counseling.
And that particular
program has been receiving
700 calls with students every week,
so they're being really
helpful to make sure
the students are dealing
with whatever anxiety
or other issues they have
as they complete their term.
Now, we recognize that
there are other kinds
of challenges that are being exasperated
by this particular health crisis.
Dean Brown mentioned one of them.
COVID-19 is affecting
different populations
differently based on race
and socioeconomic status,
as she mentioned, including
here in New Haven.
We're conscious of that as it plays
out in the community, the
campus community as well.
And of course, there is news nationally
of the rise in racial discrimination
against Asians and Asian Americans,
and we want people to know
that we have resources
available to support people,
because we really want to support those
who are facing harassment
and discrimination.
So we have a team of people
around the university
who are working very hard to make sure
that the community is taken care of,
and that we can connect with each other.
I encourage you, all of
us, to support each other
as we go through this process of trying to
not only continue to flatten the curve,
but also to prepare to turn the corner
that both you and Scott have described.
- Great, thank you very much, Kim.
Kim, Nancy, Scott, Pericles,
I want to thank you all
for what you're doing for our community.
Kim, I'd be interested in
hearing some of the questions
that you've been collecting
from participants,
so why don't we turn
to those questions now.
- Good.
So a lot of people submitted questions,
so thank you, everybody.
The first question is for Nancy.
Nancy, the question you're being asked is,
"When faculty, students,
and staff return to campus,
"what will we do to reduce the possible
"transmission of COVID-19
in terms of cleaning,
"social distancing, (mumbles) and alike?"
Thank you for the question, yeah.
- Okay.
So first I would say we will adhere
to current state and city guidelines
at the time that we reopen,
and these in turn will
depend on the prevalence
of infection at that time.
And so we may need to make changes
as the characteristics of the epidemic
and that guidance changes.
I'd say social distancing
is the fundamental strategy,
and it's going to include modifying
our physical spaces and
our movement pattern
so that we increase
distances in the classrooms,
in our labs, our offices,
the dining halls,
our common spaces in the dorms.
Depending on the guidance
and prevalence of infection,
we may need to require masks,
and we may need to limit large gatherings.
Our colleagues in
Environmental Health services
are already developing
plans for enhanced cleaning
through the school and the dorms.
Yale Health, as you know, offers testing
and contact tracing for individuals
who develop symptoms.
And I think it's going
to be very important
that we facilitate the
ability of our students
and our faculty and staff to self-isolate
and also to obtain medical care as needed,
and of course, we've already
developed the systems
to do this for our health care workers
over the last several months.
- Thank you, Nancy.
We have a lot of questions
related to research.
So Scott, I'll ask you,
"When do you think
research labs will open,
"and how can we open them safely?"
- Yeah, it's a great question.
Like most of the people
that asks that question,
it's a question I'd like
to know the answer to
because, I like others,
I'm a faculty member
who has a research lab
whose work was suspended.
We had just received a new federal grant
to do work that we were
excited to perform,
but in order to follow
public health guidelines,
that work has stopped,
and the lab has been been cleared.
But of course, we, like
others, are anxious
to get that work started again,
but we need to do it in a safe way.
And it's not just work in laboratories,
it's also work that's done in libraries
with collections and access to the various
and amazing resources that are available
to the faculty staff and
students at the university.
It's important that we
move carefully, safely,
and within public health guidelines
that Nancy just described,
and also in compliance
with government policy.
I was interested to hear
that Governor Lamont
emphasized that university research
is one of the functions
that he would like to see
reopened soon in an announcement he made
in the past day.
We expect we'll be able to
reactivate research labs
and the libraries before we have students
in the classrooms and the dining halls,
as I mentioned before.
The densities are lower,
it's easier to socially distance.
It's often the case
that personal protective
equipment is worn in these spaces,
particularly in the laboratories,
and so we anticipate
that we'll be able to,
something that we can do
before the fall semester
and hopefully substantially
sooner than that.
As I described, there
are Research Continuity
Committees being chaired by Mike Crair
and Susan Gibbons,
and their deliberations have gone on
for about almost two weeks,
and we expect the report will be completed
and released in the next week or two.
They have worked very
hard and very effectively.
Let's be clear, this
will not be an immediate
return to work, and the
work that we're doing
will not look like it
did when we were working
in those spaces in February.
After that report is released,
that guidance is released,
each research group will need to consider
how their operation can be achieved
within the safe and
operational requirements
of the phased reactivation
that will be described
in this committee report.
Each group will need to think
through those questions.
But let's also be clear,
we will reactivate our
labs and libraries soon.
We will do it safely and we will follow
public health guidance and
government recommendations.
Yale will return to
(mumbles) productivity.
- Thank you, Scott.
The next set of questions
have to do with financial aid.
"Will financial aid be
affected in the fall,
"and will Yale college financial aid
"be re-evaluated given the
economic circumstances?"
Peter, I think that's for you.
- Okay.
Thank you for that question
about financial aid.
Look, the university has taken
a substantial financial hit.
However, and I wanna be
crystal clear about this,
our commitment to our
need-based financial aid
policies is unwavering.
Now students in Yale
college, if you're watching,
if your family circumstances have changed,
you should bring that
information to the attention
of the Office of
Undergraduate Financial Aid.
They'll be ready to help you.
- Great, thank you, Peter.
I see we have a lot of questions,
very specific questions from students
about leave policies, looks like housing,
retrieving and storing
belongings left on campus,
grading in the fall and the like.
Students, I would say that your deans
are all looking at many of these issues,
and they will be communicating
with you directly
in the weeks and months ahead.
So look for those emails.
We also have a lot of
questions about commencement,
and I wanna let you know
that we are definitely
going to be welcoming the Class of 2020
back in person to campus.
We just don't know exactly
when because we have to wait
for public health guidelines to tell us
when we can invite several
thousand people back
to be here for traditional
Yale ceremonies.
But when we know that,
we will let you know.
And I do wanna tell you
that we're gonna have
all the pomp and circumstances
that we normally would have
as a traditional ceremony.
But we're also gonna celebrate you twice
because we're gonna have
a special celebration
with President Salovey actually conferring
your degrees May 18th,
and we'll send you some more information
about that as well.
So look forward to that,
and we look forward to welcoming you back
in person later on.
Okay, I think that might be
all the questions I can see.
- Okay, thank you, Kim, appreciate that,
and we appreciate those
who sent questions.
We know there's others that are out there
and we'll try to answer
them in other ways.
So let me conclude by saying this.
At Yale, we're going to
continue to pursue our mission.
We'll be educating students in the fall,
we'll be conducting research more fully
as soon as it is safe to do so.
Our financial challenges are serious,
but with your help and
guided by our principles,
we can work through them.
Someday we'll look back on this period,
and we'll know that our university emerged
from it stronger and more unified,
and that research universities like Yale
made substantial
contributions to addressing
this horrible global crisis.
I wanna thank everyone for what you do
and what you will continue
to do for our community,
and for joining this conversation today.
We'll keep you updated quite regularly.
And we'll do that through email,
we'll do that through another town hall
that we are going to schedule,
most likely for July,
and we'll speak more at that time
about the fall semester.
In the meantime,
as Kim suggested at the beginning of this,
please visit covid19.yale.edu,
covid19.yale.edu for
the latest information.
And to keep up with late breaking news,
please look at Yale Today
in your morning email.
I wanna thank everyone for
attending this town hall.
Thank you for all that you're doing
under these challenging circumstances.
Thank you so much.